-Performing "Substance" from
their new album, "Holy F,"
once again, Demi Lovato!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Is anybody happy
with life in the back seat? ♪
♪ Trying to master
the art of detaching ♪
♪ Is anybody driving,
is anyone asking? ♪
♪ Is anyone grasping
that nothing lasts? ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ I know we're all exhausted ♪
♪ Am I in my head
or have we all lost it? ♪
♪ So I ask myself, am I ♪
♪ The only one looking
for substance? ♪
♪ Got high ♪
♪ It only left me lonely
and loveless ♪
♪ Don't wanna end up in a
casket, head full of maggots ♪
♪ Body full of jack...
I get an abundance ♪
♪ Am I ♪
♪ The only one looking
for substance?
♪ I don't remember last week,
got my head scratching ♪
♪ But everyone's acting
like nothing is lacking ♪
♪ Think we might be crashing,
everyone's laughing ♪
♪ Time is just passing yet,
nothing lasts ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ I know we're all exhausted ♪
♪ Am I in my head
or have we all lost it? ♪
♪ So I ask myself, am I ♪
♪ The only one looking
for substance? ♪
♪ Got high ♪
♪ It only left me lonely
and loveless ♪
♪ Don't wanna end up in a
casket, head full of maggots ♪
♪ Body full of jack...
I get an abundance ♪
♪ Am I ♪
♪ The only one looking
for substance?
♪ Am I talking to myself? ♪
♪ Is anyone out there ♪
♪ Screaming at the walls? ♪
♪ I can't relate at all ♪
♪ Relate at all ♪
♪ The theatrics,
what happened to classic? ♪
♪ Give me the real...
give me the magic ♪
♪ So I ask myself, am I ♪
♪ The only one looking
for substance? ♪
♪ Got high ♪
♪ It only left me
lonely and loveless ♪
-♪ Don't wanna end up in a ♪
-♪ Casket ♪
-♪ Head full of ♪
-♪ Maggots ♪
-♪ Body full of ♪
-♪ Jack...♪
-♪ I get an ♪
-♪ Abundance ♪
♪ Am I ♪
♪ The only one looking
for substance? ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh! Come on!